Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number that is
two one nine two. David P. You can call anytime.
Here's a really interesting question about some
of the coverage I've done of the things Joe Rogan
has said recently. And the caller is asking Why
aren't other people on the left doing similar
coverage? It's an interesting topic. Let's listen.
Speaker 7: Hey, David. First of all, a huge fan of
the show. One thing I'd like to give you a shout
out for is you being able to call out other people
like Joe Rogan such a more powerful than yourself.
And one thing that's really been bothering me is a
lot of people on the left on Reddit. You call
them the so-called left, but I notice three
avoid criticizing people like Joe Rogan and Jimmy
Dore. And then when they are called out on it,
they say, Well, oh, you know, I'm personal
friends with them, so you have to understand
that it's uncomfortable, blah blah blah.
Speaker 2: And it's like part of me
Speaker 7: sees where they're coming from. But
look, man, I worked in a grocery store for a year
and a half of COVID. If you think I didn't have
to call out friends who have no way longer than
any of these people, like Jimmy Dore, Joe
Rogan, like I'm talking to like 10 years,
like I've worked with these people like that's far
more uncomfortable than calling out of work. So
like people saying like, Oh, you know, you got
to understand it's uncomfortable. Like, Dude,
I'm the first one to say, it's uncomfortable.
I've had to do it in way more uncomfortable
circumstance and like, look, this is a once
every hundred year pandemic. This is important.
I hope. People still like me, but at the
end of the day, I don't care, you know?
Speaker 1: Yeah, and and the caller goes on a bit.
I can't really speak to why anybody else does or
doesn't do criticism of anything in particular.
You know, sometimes people will write to me and
they'll say, David, why haven't you said anything
about this or that? And it's like, sometimes I
just don't have anything to say about it. I will
tell you that there are people who, when I've done
segments critical of the things Joe Rogan has
Speaker 2: said about whatever COVID
related vaccines,
Speaker 1: ivermectin,
Speaker 2: whatever.
Speaker 1: I will get
messages from other hosts saying, I think it
was really great that you did that, actually.
Speaker 2: And they don't say why
Speaker 1: they are or aren't. You know
why they're not doing it themselves
in many cases. And I don't ask,
but everybody's got to make whatever decision
is right for that. You know, Joe Rogan's a guy
I met twice and have exchanged some messages with.
Speaker 2: And I think that on a lot of things,
Speaker 1: he has interesting insights. I think
he's gotten a lot of things just flat wrong on
COVID. And to the extent that I think that his
audience is falling for things that are wrong.
I'll do my best to correct it in a
respectful way. And as I've said before,
I have no idea whether Rogan's even aware
of the fact that I've done that coverage
Speaker 2: if he is and doesn't like
Speaker 1: it and never wants to have
me back on. That may be the case if he has no
idea that I've done it. I would go and talk to
him about it in person.
Speaker 2: I mean,
I really, for me, this is
Speaker 1: not a personal thing.
I'm seeing what's being said and who
has audiences that are listening.
And if I feel that it has to be corrected,
Speaker 2: I do it. That's my
Speaker 1: view. And then you put
aside the personal stuff. We have
a great bonus show for you today. Cornell has
Speaker 2: shut down its Ithaca campus after Major
Speaker 1: Omicron signs have been found,
while at the same time we are getting
better looking information about the severity
Speaker 2: of Omicron, which
Speaker 1: we will talk about. A Joe
Biden is set to surpass Donald Trump
in first year judicial nominees,
Speaker 2: which is a big deal.
Speaker 1: This was one of
Trump's big accomplishments
Speaker 2: judges
Speaker 1: and Joe Biden is set
to surpass Trump for that first year. We will also
talk about the House of Representatives passing a
UGA forced labor bill or weaker
forced labor bill, depending on
Speaker 2: your preferred
Speaker 1: pronunciation.
What is in it? What is its jurisdiction?
Speaker 2: We'll talk about it on the bonus show.
Speaker 1: You can sign up at join Packman dot
com. Excuse me. Also, remember that on January
1st, we will be doing a single day membership
special to kick off the new year. If you'd like to
participate, just get on our mailing list at David
Pakman. Incom, we will see you on today's vote.